yeah lovie did it too
yeah this is the thing we're gonna just
do for the next
day or hour or century
oh how do i go from generic to the real
deal
[Music]
and just drop the first three letters of
generic
beth harmon time if you beat all 8
levels do you win a date with beth
uh probably but she's
imaginary right or she's just a robot so
i don't know
first step is beating level one
okay so um this was announced earlier
today i think
and i have no idea
how difficult these will be there's
eight years old
there's nine years old she keeps getting
older
so do i do i speedrun beth harmon
or do i do i take it slowly and just
try and prove my my dominance at least
among like
the lower levels
i'll start with yeah i'll start with h8
and then
we'll work our way up we'll see how high
we can go and
along the way i'll try and play some
tricky and fun
maybe some dubious openings i'll try and
get in at least a few queens gambits
and hopefully a stafford gambit and
i don't know about the sodium attack i
don't even know what that is
but let's do this okay aj's let's go
friendly wait what i don't think i'm
gonna need help
three three take backs and hints
we're gonna do challenge i i don't need
any help i don't think
okay let's do this i'm white um
do i just go for like the dirty scholars
mates
i'm trying to remember the first episode
she just got mated in four moves right
no the first episode you know what she
played
i think it was um bishop c4 knight c6
queen h5 and then knight d4
so would she repeat that or [ __ ] has she
already learned her lesson let's play
this move
oh okay i'm happy with this ha ha
this is a classic like even real humans
fall into this
this is a classic one wait what don't
trap my queen
oh that's actually kind of like almost
disturbing
thankfully i have i have a free pawn
at some point i'll probably throw in a
check
but let's continue expanding
um
is she gonna play queen b4 oh
f6 ben feingold would be pleased
okay let's take this
oh the queen bond cloud novelty
or maybe still theory i don't know what
is this
where's my mate oh look at this
i've only got two queens
yeah so check here here
no wait what oh i forgot knights could
move backwards
oh i was so excited okay i'll just take
all her pieces
what is bishop e5 okay maybe i should
slow down
what
this is this is too much fun
i'm not proud of this game i've already
made like a few oversights but
i can't complain threatening made in two
i wonder is this some moment where i
should walk away
and announce maiden 2
no i'll just calmly deliver it
okay i want a game thank you
whatever your name was something bear
subbing a tier one
let's go so quick chess lesson
because i there's probably a lot of new
players
like players new to chess or
just getting into chess that
don't know about this
but most people okay most people know
about like the four move checkmates
but not everyone knows how to actually
respond to it as black
g6 it attacks the queen but loses a rook
so the best move here is knight c6 can i
analyze
how do i analyze analysis
okay so in this um in this position
g6 is uh
is like the common mistake knight c6
best move defend the pawn
and then bishop c4
actually my very first over the board
tournament when i was eight years old
i had this position as black
and i played bishop c5 and i lost in
four moves
it was really sad so if you're black
here you need to defend f7
um i'll show a cool line i'll show a
line that even if
like you're a decent player you may have
not seen before
um and we'll look from black side
um if if you're yeah you shouldn't be
doing this if you're white
unless you're playing against beth
harman h8 so the best move for black is
g6
because now the pawn is defended white
will
usually play queen f3 threatening made
again
and again we have to defend so i think
in in episode one of queen's gambit
beth oh beth had like this position
and played knight d4 i believe
and then just got mated
a knight d4 like is normally a good move
if it doesn't hang pain in one the best
move here is knight f6
and now there is a way for white to
continue attacking
it seems like okay now black's really
safe but there's a move queen b3
creating a battery i'm going to give the
question to chat
black to move what would you play here
what's the strongest move
a lot of moves being suggested d5 being
suggested
king e7 reverse bond cloud knight d4
queen e7
do i have the engine oh i have the
engine turned on what i thought i
closed that oh well good job chat for
reading the engine
how do i turn off the engine no
i could just hide let me just hide it
let me hide this thing
i don't need that thing we just need the
board
yeah we're going minimal okay this is
better
so i can see the engine line the chat
can't
but good job knight d4 so we allow white
to take
on f7 oh no my scene
oh no oh no my pawn
but this time it's not mate because we
have king e7
and now white's in a situation where the
queen's attacked
but the queen's also tied down to
defending the bishop
and the only move to save the queen
while still defending the bishop is
queen
c4 and now
black to move how does black win
material from this position
after tragically losing a pawn
wow chad is finding it without even
seeing the engine
good job oh but it's not d5
d5 uh and d5 maybe works but there's
bishop d5
but b5 yeah
so this is how you punish scholars mates
or at least a scholars made attempt is
by developing your pieces
and then when the opportunity is right
you strike
and now you're attacking the queen
you're controlling all the squares along
this diagonal
and you're going to win the bishop
now there's one more bonus trap um
because if you get this to this position
and white will kind of realize
the fact that the bishop's going to be
lost the natural move here is queen c3
uh we take the bishop and now let's say
d3
and this is a bonus tactic black to move
win even more material that's a nice
tactic here
experienced chess players will find the
move pretty quickly for black
i'm curious like for more beginner chess
players
how quickly they'll find it maybe
they'll find it quickly if they're
reading chat
good job chat oh good job to yash
yash is naming the name of the tactic
so in this position we're gonna pork
white
we're gonna use a combination of a pin
and a fork
it's the pork we pin the queen
now the bishop's not defended by
anything
but it's defended by tactics
so when white takes we we fork and we we
win the queen
anyway that's my lesson on
on scholars mates i think this is a
lesson that
everyone should have like relatively
early on
in their their chess journey
because you should know you should know
about the four move checkmates
but you should also know how to stop it
can you skewer
can you skewer a pork uh you would just
need a stick
probably you should put that on youtube
oh good idea very good idea
there were there was some technical
hurdles but
uh if this goes on youtube it's all
thanks to eyes
one one three two seven so youtube
people
say hi to twitch chat and twitch chat
say hi to youtube people hear switch
hats
they're being so frog like
but also welcoming
oh so someone said hi editor where's
where was that hi editor the editor is
me
i do all the editing so uh hello back
oh cheers yeah
thanks for the cheer but also the sub
westie's good
and say hi to gm derek who is somewhere
and gabador live and everyone else
what if i just leave like what if i just
make the youtube video
several minutes longer than necessary
and the rest of the video is just twitch
chat
saying random stuff and cheering random
stuff
hello future peeps
because then i would it would increase
watch time but would people actually
watch this
i don't know
i'm really not sure
but thanks people for being so chattery
yeah i could add like an extra ad i
could just put an ad at the end of the
video